[Musique - La Marseillaise]
Salut.
Si, aujourd'hui, je vous retrouve
dans le bureau présidentiel
de l'Élysée,
c'est pas pour rien.
C'est pour quelque chose d'important !
Et c'est quoi ?
[Imitant N. Sarkozy]
Bé, j'vais vous le dire.
Nous allons élire
le nouveau Président de Youtube.
Et ça, c'est pas rien
mon pote...
[Musique Générique]
C'est bon ? On m'entend ?
Parfait.
Si je vous ai réunis ici, aujourd'hui,
c'est pour une question
de démocratie.
[Effet sonore "Public / Foule"]
Haaaaaaa !
Il y a quelque temps, lors d'un hors série
sur cette scène,
un débat avait fait rage :
Est-ce que je refaisais des vidéos
de divertissement
le samedi matin, une fois de temps
en temps, en Hors Série ?
Vous avez... voté !
Enfin... il n'y a pas eu de vote,
mais vous avez été nombreux
à répondre dans les commentaires.
Et j'avais dit que je referai ces vidéos,
le jour où j'aurais compris
où est-ce qu'était mon erreur...
Je pense l'avoir trouvée.
En plus, vous avez été plus de
20.000 à mettre des likes.
["Foule"] Wouhaouuuuu !
Et enfin, aussi, parce que toute
la communauté silencieuse s'est réveillée !
Pour que cette vidéo là
voit le jour !
[Caricaturant Sarkozy]
Et alors, en France, quand le peuple
va dans la rue,
ben... on ne l'écoute pas toujours...
Et bé moi, sur ma chaîne,
quand vous venez dans
l'espace commentaires,
et bé je vous écoute.
[Foule en délire]
Il n'a pas, un peu, un arrière-goût
d'Enrico Macias mon Sarko ?
Bref !
Je remets ma cravate invisible,
je réajuste mon costard en cuir
et c'est parti.
Nous allons donc faire, ensemble,
une petite expérience surprenante.
Attention !!!
Je n'ai pas dit forcément
ultra-bluffante,
j'ai dit surprenante
et amusante.
Car : oui ! Nous allons élire le
nouveau Président de Youtube !
Alors, le Président peut être
un Youtubeur ou une Youtubeuse,
mais, également, un concept
de vidéo.
A l'issue de ces primaires,
ont été déclarés candidats validés
avec plus de 500 milliards de signatures,
tout ça, je ne sais pas quoi...
Norman,
les vidéos reprenant les vidéos
des autres illégalement,
Pierre Croce,
les réactions aux Musically
et les vidéos "Réaction"
d'une manière générale...
Ennoba,
les vidéos de prank,
Antoine Daniel,
les vidéos "dégustation"
et enfin, Amixem.
Ce choix de candidats a été fait
en suivant la manière
la plus démocratique qu'il soit,
c'est à dire celle de Corée du Nord :
entre moi et moi-même.
Juste avant de commencer,
quelques précisions à vous donner :
écoutez les bien !
Parce que, après, sinon...
vous allez galérer.
Pour cette balade  électorale,
je vais vous inviter à poser
le doigt sur votre écran.
Mais si vous avez un
écran tactile,
comme un téléphone portable
ou un iPad,
ne mettez pas le doigt
directement dessus...
parce que, sinon, ça va
faire pause.
Et la vidéo va vous paraître
très longue...
N'allez jamais plus vite que moi.
Écoutez bien les consignes
que je vous donne.
[Articulant exagérément] Écoutez bien
les consignes que je vous donne.
Et surtout, n'hésitez pas
à mettre pause
quand vous trouvez que
ça va trop vite.
Une dernière chose :
Rassurez vous,
il n'y a pas de calcul à faire.
Mes chers concitoyens,
voici les 9 candidats en lice
pour cette élection interactive
du nouveau Président de Youtube.
Vous allez commencer par choisir
un Youtubeur.
Alors, non pas un concept de vidéo,
mais j'ai bien dit : un Youtubeur.
Donc : Amixem, Pierre Croce,
Ennoba, Antoine Daniel
ou Norman.
Vous posez votre doigt, sur la case
du Youtubeur que vous avez choisi.
Allez-y maintenant.
Je répète quand même,
vous choisissez
soit Amixem,
soit Pierre Croce,
soit Ennoba,
soit Antoine Daniel,
soit Norman,
et vous mettez votre doigt dessus.
La balade va enfin pourvoir commencer.
[Sonnerie de téléphone ancien - DRIIIINNNNG]
Oui ?
Ah... toujours ces problèmes de droits...
On les respecte ?
On les respecte.
Et bé, alors... d'accord.
On le disqualifie.
Un candidat vient d'être
disqualifié d'office,
donc, je vais l'enlever,
voilà, c'est terminé pour les vidéos...
qui pompent sur les vidéos
des autres.
Pour commencer, vous allez déplacer
votre doigt de 5 cases.
Alors, attendez avant de le faire,
je vais vous expliquer, ce sera le cas
pour tout le long de cette balade.
Vous pouvez aller en ligne ;
Vous pouvez aller en colonne ;
Vous pouvez faire des allers-retours,
vous pouvez revenir sur vos pas,
vous pouvez faire juste :
avant-arrière-avant-arrière...
Les deux seules choses que vous
ne pouvez pas faire,
c'est : sauter des cases...
C'est comme un chemin :
on ne se téléporte pas.
Donc, les cases sont toujours d'affilée.
Et, la deuxième chose, c'est qu'on
ne se déplace pas en diagonale.
Je répète  :
Vous ne sautez pas de cases,
vous ne bougez pas en diagonale,
mais, par contre, vous pouvez
faire tout le reste.
Histoire d'être sûr que l'on fasse bien
les choses en même temps,
je vais claquer des doigts
à chaque déplacement de case.
Comme ça, vous suivrez bien.
Quand je ferai ça [CLAC] pour
la première fois,
vous allez bouger votre doigt
de la case où vous êtes actuellement,
pour aller vers une case adjacente,
vers la droite, vers le haut,
vers le bas ou vers la gauche.
Et on comptera : 1
C'est bien clair ?
Alors : vous avez votre doigt sur
le Youtubeur que vous avez choisi au départ...
Allez-y, vous vous déplacez d'une case.
[CLAC]
[CLAC] 2ème case.
[CLAC]Une 3ème case
[CLAC] Une 4ème case
[CLAC] Et enfin, d'une 5ème case.
Vous êtes maintenant sur une nouvelle case,
ne bougez pas.
Parce que j'ai une information
qui m'a été remise de manière confidentielle,
et qui stipule qu'Amixem
s'est fait dénoncer dans la presse
par le Canard enchaîné
pour usage de titres putaclic...
Alors, on n'a pas encore de preuve, hein...
Comme quoi les titres seraient en majuscules
ou putaclics...
On n'a pas de preuve de ça,
en plus, Amixem, c'est un pote,
mais...
dans le doute, il décide de se retirer
de cette élection.
Amixem...
Over !
Monde cruel qu'est la politique !
Par contre, on a eu un coup de chance,
c'est que vous n'étiez pas sur la case d'Amixem.
Vous avez donc le doigt toujours sur une case,
on va continuer notre chemin
en faisant 4 déplacements.
Toujours les mêmes règles.
Où vous voulez,
les allers-retours comme vous voulez,
mais pas de diagonale
et on ne saute pas de case.
Bougez une fois [CLAC]
[CLAC] 2 fois
[CLAC] 3 fois
[CLAC] 4 fois.
Et là, il est l'heure de vous dire
qu'une autre personne se retire
du game...
C'est Pierre Croce.
On n'enlève pas son
"Alors, évidemment, bonjour à tous"
impunément...
Pierre...
Je te retire du Game.
Je ne sais pas si tu regarderas cette vidéo,
mais je te retire du Game.
Enfin... du Game de ma vidéo...
Mais heureusement, et c'est toujours aussi étonnant,
vous n'étiez pas sur Pierre Croce.
Votre doigt est toujours sur une case,
on continue ce petit chemin électoral
et démocratique...
C'est parti, vous bougez d'une case
[CLAC] maintenant
et encore d'une autre case [CLAC]
[DRIIINNNG] Stop ! Encore ?
Il n'y a que des stops.
Alors, qu'est-ce qu'il y a ?
Oui Antoine, je t'écoute...
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Ah, tu veux être retiré, toi aussi,
de la campagne...
Parce qu'il te faut un peu plus de temps
pour pouvoir préparer le What The Cut N°38 ?
Ah ben oui !
On aimerait tous ça, bien sûr.
Oui, je te parle sur un téléphone
qui n'est pas du tout branché
puisqu'on ne se connaît pas du tout
dans la vraie vie.
Alors attends, ne quitte pas,
je vérifie si quelqu'un a son doigt sur toi...
Euh... et bé non
personne.
Bon ben c'est bon, je te retire de la campagne.
Antoine Daniel avait besoin de temps.
A partir de maintenant,
pour la deuxième partie,
on va aller un petit peu plus vite
dans les déplacements, ok ?
On est parti, vous bougez votre doigt
maintenant [CLAC]
Encore une fois [CLAC]
Encore une fois [CLAC]     STOP !
Parce que je suis en train de me demander
s'il n'y a pas une caméra quelque part...
Est-ce que cette vidéo ne serait pas un prank ?
Est-ce que je ne suis pas en train de me faire piéger ?
Est-ce que JE vais faire des pranks, moi,
sur ma chaîne ?
Je ne sais pas.
Je propose...
que nous supprimions les pranks de l'élection.
Un prank ne peut pas devenir Président
et comme je vois que personne n'a le doigt
sur la case Prank...
Ben, je me permets de l'enlever.
Et on est reparti.
Déplacez votre doigt...
[CLAC] Une fois
et
[CLAC] encore une fois
On s'arrête là, ne bougez pas pour l'instant,
gardez bien votre doigt ici.
Il est très bien là où il est, là...
Et moi, çà va me permettre d'enlever cette case
qui est complétement vide de votre doigt,
qui est la case des "Réactions"
aux Musically
Je me dis : si on enlève les pranks,
on peut aussi enlever celle-ci,
puisque personne n'est dessus pour le moment...
hein ...
Allez, on l'enlève.
Réfléchissez bien à la case où vous allez vouloir
aller maintenant...
Puisqu'on va se déplacer qu'une seule fois.
Attention... déplacez votre doigt...
Maintenant [CLAC]
Et, comme vous avez commencé à le comprendre,
à chaque arrêt,
nous enlevons quelqu'un, ou une case...
Et là, il s'avère que personne n'est sur Norman !
En même temps, pourquoi pas
parce que ce n'est pas très bien
de montrer quelqu'un du doigt...
Puisque personne n'est sur Norman,
si vous êtes sur Norman : criez bien fort...
Non ? Personne !
Alors, on enlève la case de Norman.
Et, pour terminer, vous allez bouger 3 fois votre doigt...
[CLAC] Une fois
[CLAC] Deux fois
3 fois !!!  [CLAC]
Terminé !      Stop !
Double stop même ! Parce que,
comment ça se fait qu'on a laissé la case dégustation ?
Vous voulez vraiment qu'il y ait un ministère
des vidéos "Dégustation" ?
Non ! Personne ne veut ça !
Réellement, personne ne veut ça,
parce que personne n'a son doigt dessus,
donc j'enlève la case des vidéos "Dégustation".
Et il nous reste qu'une seule case d'ailleurs.
La case d'Ennoba !
Le nouveau Président de Youtube serait donc Ennoba ?
En tout cas, il y a quelque chose d'intéressant,
c'est que, tout le long, vous avez fait
ce que vous vouliez, vous ;
Depuis votre choix de départ,
sur le chemin que vous preniez...
Et à chaque fois que j'enlevais une case,
vous n'aviez pas le doigt sur cette case.
Sauf !!!
Si vous n'avez pas écouté une des consignes
depuis le départ...
Mais alors : qui est ce Ennoba ?
Qui est ce nouveau Président de Youtube ?
Ce Président qui a fait que vous avez
tous voté pour lui,
et oui, je me déplace, parce que
je suis au Youtube Space pour filmer ça...
Mes chers compatriotes,
vous l'avez compris :
le Président de Youtube
Ennoba
c'est vous !
Ce sont les abonnés.
Depuis toujours, c'est vous les tauliers !
Alors merci d'être ici.
Merci d'écouter nos vidéos,
car je continue de promouvoir
ma grande campgne du
Pour que ce soit pour moi
ou pour tous les autres créateurs,
ça nous fait toujours plaisir
quand vous réagissez,
par un like, un com,
et même par autre chose...
Et, du coup, j'espère que cette nouvelle vidéo
vous aura surprise et amusée
puisque c'était le but !
A quand un nouvel Hors Série ?
Je n'en sais rien !
Ça dépendra encore du bruit
que vous ferez sur cette vidéo...
[Chantant] #PASSILENCIEUX...
je crois qu'on a compris...
Et moi, je vous dis : à très bientôt !
Ciao !
[Musique Générique de Fin]